có chình thân ra ra thông suy hiện các tình hôm hát quan khiến miệng số bị chem ở chức số như
thật nhất, mưa, đường lên lỗi hoặc tình hôm bất lợi giãn đến miệng số bị mùn đất, mùi, mạnh,
chế phùm ở chức số, lai xe sẽ không bị sự phạt lời với hình vi, điều khiến xe gắn biệng số không gió chữ, số,
gió đe là tình ũ sẽ ra phát quan, bất khả tháng.
Đường với các tình hỗ tệ sẽ dí trình liên tục trong quán đường hành trình,
thậm chí đi trên đường cao tốc thì không bột phải dừng đấu ngày để làm sạch biệng số,
sau khi gặp được kích quán làm biệng số bị chè phù chữ, số trên biệng cạnh sát xa thông sẽ không suy phát.
Tuy nhiên, khi dừng khi chình hòa có điểm dừng đấu đủ được kịt an toàn,
quyến cao lai xe cần làm sạch niệm bệng số,
lực lượng cạnh sát xa thông sẽ xử phạt lời với các chiếm vào bệng xấu bình lâu ngày,
khoặc đá dừng đấu, liếp biệng số bị chè phù, nhưng vẫn tích tục gì chuyện.
Thì biệng dừng xe, tài xe gặp tình hôm bất khả háng có thể dài chình với cạnh sát xa thông,
lực lượng sẽ xử dụng các vị phát biệng bụ để xác mình,
thông qua hệ thông các mẹ ra xam xát, các mẹ ra hình chình,
trước khi ra phy định sự phạt biệng phạng hình chình.
Cuy định của phóc lực vị sự phạt lời với hình vi để biệng số bị chè phù bờ hoặc xán xe biệng số,
cũng nhằm phòng chánh thơ đối tượng lượng lượng việc các quán chức năng và hệ thông xam xát không nhận biệng số xe để thực hiện biệng phạm xa thông,
khoặc thực hiện tối phạm chiến đường.